[Música]
en exclusivo francés 24 bienvenidos
estamos con el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro para preguntarle cómo
avanza la economía de este país de
sudamericano presidente Gracias por
estar con nosotros en France 24 y le
pregunto primero Cuáles son las
proyecciones económicas para este año en
este país Hola Daniela todo el clima
mundial y el que llega a Colombia pues
tiene mensajes
pesimistas
el alza la tasa de interés
indudablemente nos ha golpeado devaluó
nuestra moneda al devaluarla de manera
extrema
todos los productos alimenticios que
importábamos los fertilizantes
se encarecieron
insumos estratégicos para la
alimentación y encareciendo la
producción Nacional de alimentos ha
elevado el hambre en de una manera
sustancial el hambre más la crisis
climática porque llevamos diez meses
bajo el agua literalmente
Parece que son otros meses los que
tenemos que vivir con más de un millón
de damnificados la destrucción de medio
país en carreteras vías
todo esto conjuntamente pues provoca un
escenario que no es pesimista pero
ahí en medio de esas circunstancias
Tratamos de desarrollar una reforma
agraria
Tratamos de volver rentable la
producción alimenticia para disminuir el
hambre estamos
seriamente comprometidos con un proceso
de paz Total que busca disminuir al
máximo la violencia en Colombia con sus
dificultades porque se trata de temas
complejos
Tratamos de transitar hacia un país de
energías limpias de alistarse a lo que
será una economía descarbonizada y
buscamos la unidad de América Latina de
muy diversas formas
Y entonces Son elementos que nos dan
optimismo para este año que vamos a
vivir presidente acaba de entrar en
vigencia una reforma tributaria que
busca precisamente acabar con todos esos
vicios que hay o que ha habido
históricamente en Colombia tributa
hablando
Qué espera con esa reforma hay Quienes
se han opuesto de pronto por por ciertas
cosas pero qué se espera de esta Reforma
por primera vez en décadas
una reforma tributaria aprobada por el
congreso de Colombia no afecta a los
pobres no afecta clases medias afecta
fundamentalmente los sectores más ricos
del país que habían usado el congreso
para generar
múltiples extensiones que los hacían
pagar menos impuestos que sus propias
secretarias que sus propios empleados y
paralelamente aumentamos los impuestos a
todo lo que se llaman los combustibles
fósiles a la exportación de petróleo de
carbonas sus
disminuimos las exenciones en esos
sectores
y creemos que los recursos nuevos que
llegan que ahora vamos a gastar en
educación en la reforma agraria en los
campesinos en las mujeres que viven
solas con sus hijos y hoy tienen hambre
Nos va a garantizar más justicia social
la justicia Social es la base de la paz
la justicia Social es lo que permite
aclimatar el fin de la violencia en
Colombia presidente de Preocupaciones en
Colombia desde luego por el alza del
dólar también por el alza en las tasas
de interés usted Cuál es el llamado que
usted le hace al banco de la república
que está siguiendo más o menos la misma
política de todo el resto de bancos
centrales que seguir subiendo para
desincentivar el consumo están haciendo
lo que hace todo el mundo
que es acabar con las posibilidades de
producción y empleo con tal de reducir
la inflación
es una política discutible En mi opinión
el alza de los precios de alimentos que
es digamos el sector más poderoso de la
inflación tiene que ver con una guerra
y es esa guerra la que habría que acabar
de primera en primera instancia porque
si no no estamos solucionando los
problemas donde toca
si esa guerra no existiera si allí
hubiera un proceso de paz incentivado
por el mundo
las posibilidades de bajar los precios
del alimento serían muchos por las
condiciones de Gran potencia agraria que
tienen los dos países inmiscuidos en la
guerra el mejoramiento de las
condiciones de infracción Entonces no
necesitarían de un alza de la tasa de
interés en la magnitud que se ha dado y
las posibilidades de un crecimiento
económico y disminuir el hambre
serían mayores en todo el mundo Así que
yo creo que deberíamos comenzar por
donde toca comenzar con hacer la paz en
el mundo con asumir como principal
problema de la humanidad
no la competencia en una geopolítica que
se ha convertido una especie de suicidio
colectivo sino en resolver los problemas
de la crisis climática que son los que
pueden acabar con la vida en la tierra y
distinguir la vida humana Pues
precisamente sobre eso que habla sobre
la paz que avances ha habido en ese
proyecto de paz Total que tiene Y para
cuándo esperan ustedes que puedan tener
ya una paz total en Colombia los avances
no sin dificultades ya tienen que ver
con diálogos con seis organizaciones
armadas
diálogos que algunos más políticos otros
más socios jurídicos tienen que ver con
territorios con circunstancias de
vinculación de
juventudes a la criminalidad
internacional y que implican una
solución que no solo pasa por la
represión
lo hemos acompañado un cese al fuego un
cese de hostilidades entre los grupos el
estado etcétera que ha disminuido ya
sustancialmente en estos días de este
año que va corriendo la tasa de
homicidios del país
pero tiene dificultades indudable una
complejidad inmensa son organizaciones
que se mueven por los campos que
deberían concentrarse para facilitar la
tarea en sitios concretos
discusiones de negociación que tienen
que ver más con lo jurídico que con lo
político
la tesis de un acogimiento de la
justicia de grupos colectivos que antes
se dedicaban al narcotráfico y que
podrían dejar dedicarse a ese tipo de
actividad
complejidades que tienen que ver con que
muchos de los dirigentes de este tipo de
agrupaciones han estado en convivencia
En complicidad con grandes personas
del mundo económico del mundo político a
las cuales no les interesa que estas
personas hagan la paz y hablen y
entonces tratan de impedirlo como del
lugar porque necesitan de ese silencio
para poder mantener privilegios y usted
también hablaba crisis energética o más
bien de la el calentamiento global y
todo eso que está haciendo Colombia para
transitar hacia energías más limpias Por
qué no nos cuenta un poco sobre eso y
también sobre su participación acá en el
Foro de davos que precisamente frío
pareciera que no hubiera calentamiento
pero sí
América del Sur en general es la región
del mundo que tiene el mayor potencial
para generar energías limpias
y creo que debe unirse alrededor de este
tema porque podría
desencadenarlas en favor de la humanidad
por un lado tenemos la selva amazónica
que es una gran Esponja de CO2 que hay
que cuidar estamos procurando un gran
pacto de los países que tienen
responsabilidad territorial allí de
cofinanciar nuestra inversión y
revitalizar la selva con el mundo entero
estamos hablando de potenciar fuentes de
energías limpias a través del viento del
Sol del agua para construir
terminar prácticamente una gran red
eléctrica americana desde la Patagonia
hasta Alaska que pudiera llevar en mucho
estas energías limpias a Estados Unidos
que es hoy el principal contaminador del
mundo en términos de CO2 aquí podría
haber una alianza
concreta y real en favor de la humanidad
nosotros usando nuestro potencial de
energías limpias para que la matriz
energética de los Estados Unidos se
traslade más fácilmente hacia estas
energías
e incluso si las tecnologías del
hidrógeno verde se desarrollan podríamos
exportar en barcos las energías limpias
de América del Sur Colombia allí tiene
como los demás países un papel que
cumplir
esa transición hay que acelerarla las
posibilidades que nuestros países
Colombia tienen para cambiar su matriz
de exportaciones del petróleo del Carbón
hacia las energías limpias es altísima
pero hay que comenzar ya y finalmente le
pregunto por la amazonía ahora que llega
un nuevo gobierno al Brasil que han
pensado para prevenir la deforestación
una buena noticia yo hablé con Lula el
primero el día de la posesión una hora y
el principal tema es ese vamos a reunir
Antes que nada los grupos de expertos
los que han trabajado este tema en cada
país desde hace mucho tiempo para que se
junten En una conferencia que dé los
elementos fundamentales para lo que será
la conferencia de presidentes de la
Cuenca amazónica 10 en general entre
esos Brasil Colombia Perú Ecuador
Venezuela surinam que ha dicho que sí
Francia que tiene un departamento de su
país en terreno amazónico la Guyana
Bolivia y lograr
la construcción el empoderamiento de la
institucionalidad que hoy existe y un
gran fondo multinacional
financiado por nosotros pero también por
los países más ricos del mundo para
lograr que por lo menos en un flujo
permanente durante 20 años podemos
financiar a la población que hoy
destruye la selva pero que podría
perfectamente con esos recursos
revitalizarla volverla a su frontera
natural presidente Muchas gracias por
atendernos muy amable suerte ustedes
también gracias por su sintonía
desde davos en Suiza
[Música]